so uh mark how do we play this game
together
oh i can create a new friends only room
let me do that
yeah let's do that yeah that sounds good
i'll be there eventually
no i don't believe it come on guys
okay i made it i have no idea how you
join it but
i [ __ ] hate tutorials dude i [ __ ]
hate these things just read them
you're freaking me through the lily pads
and catch a fish okay i'm trying to
catch the
fish they make it for babies all right
i'm going in okay go ahead i'm
apparently in your room
okay i don't see you yet i caught one
i did it that's great man i'm by the
bridge you by the bridge
what bridge the the territorial bridge
oh
[Music]
hey stop breathing heavy tell me how to
find you
stop it uh bob
hello hi
god damn it i've got no all right so i'm
right in front of you no
where'd you go one minute wait hang on
slowly backing up and then go go fishing
at the top
place on the map all right i'm like
right next to you right now yeah hang on
yeah i see you wait
oh yeah oh you're backing away you're
back you're backing away
okay what is with this leg what is
happening all right you don't move
don't move i'm not gonna move i'm not
gonna move all right are we right in
front of each other right now hey wade's
behind you is he
i don't i don't want to turn around and
see no turn and look
okay i'm turning look i want to see it
there he is
hey what's up man oh no
oh no
we can't get too close to each other
because there's too
much input delay all right you guys
ready to get crappy yeah you want to get
fishing
well do we want to go like fish off the
bridge yeah bruh that sounds
lovely let's stream off the bridge like
we're family
yeah yeah yeah there's a bridge here oh
there's over this way son
i'll be on this end okay oh there you go
okay
goodbye i'll be in the middle i'll try
this side
i'll be on the right and i'll be really
close to you all
guys do you see all the little water
bloops around look at that yeah are
those fish oh yeah they're just bloops
i would assume that they're fish or i
might have some might have some yeah
something's nibbling might have some oh
yeah something's terrible
here we go yeah oh it's tiny i got a
green sunfish
oh hell yeah guys when you open your
inventory
the music starts yeah why is there no
sound it goes from dead silent
to if you hit i it's all
why is there no game sound effect do you
have to buy that is that part of the
pack
yeah the the game sound pack it says
sound volume but no
where'd you go where am i becoming
invisible when you're in your inventory
oh yeah my noises don't line up with
anything
[Laughter]
all right i'm back oh hey there you are
no you're not
you're still invisible come on buddy i'm
here
hello oh there you are let's just catch
some fish yeah let's get some
let's get fishing like shoot dang it
yeah let's get some
i feel like i picked the bad spot
there's not [ __ ] happening over here
oh it's working i'm getting some nibs oh
i
wheeled it in too much oh you got
nibbles hell yeah go get a man
you got this look at that a trophy white
crack got another whitey in here i don't
see it yet but
damn dag you'll see it look at that
caught a one and a quarter pound trophy
white crappy i caught some weeds
did you actually catch weeds yeah i
caught sweeties
wait really wait did you reel it in
already oh i see
a hornwort little tiny little shitty
weed on it
does it tell you i caught it let's say
lord minion pulled out oh
there's i got worms you caught worms
there's a pile here
oh [ __ ] it's a free worm pile
i'm rewarded for red worm with red worms
is this how fishing is in real life yeah
man you're wandering around
find a pile of dirt on someone's
property like hey i'm taking some worms
for this bad boy you just go find
someone has water and you go fish in
there yeah
i mean so like not to rush it but did
you guys unlock the new pond yet
no no i need i think i need like one
more catcher no apparently catching the
hornwort
did not give me much experience wait how
are you so bad at everything that we do
all right i'm gonna really really swang
it
okay you really can't swing it
no i'm trying to see it doesn't seem to
be any swanging yeah why's nothing
fish from inside of you you guys are
caught some i caught a [ __ ] weeds
well is this good stratagems yeah let's
dual wield this [ __ ]
this is this is hey i caught one
no oh it's it's the tiniest golden shine
around you
stole my fish damn it i'm i'm gonna keep
that delightful fish i just got
challenged complete oh god damn it
all right you know what i'm mad i can't
even get a nibble i'm gonna go
fish by weight i'm gonna steal his fish
there's no fish here
oh different okay marcus is gonna cast
in and in two seconds he's literally
gonna
start catching stuff i know this is kind
of the one right here a meme that we're
enjoying this as a joke but can i say
it's actually pretty relaxing
no it's super really i'm allowed to say
that it's like real life fishing you
don't actually have to do anything a lot
of the time
yeah real life is more about like
hanging out talking and telling stories
while you wait for something to happen i
think
ask your dad why you want to kiss that
girl out of the mouth i haven't gotten
asked that question in a long time but
yeah
oh sorry wait asking your dad why he
wants to kiss that girl or
you no like why your pee pee feels funny
when you look at the girl in your class
that you like or whatever you know
questions about
growing up stuff i stole fish right
under wade's nose oh god
damn it yeah read dear sunfish he's a
bigon
challenge complete hell yeah
i unlocked cheese i
unlocked cheese oh my god another one
right under underwear
[ __ ] i'm gonna take a picture of that
one take a picture i'm taking a picture
of that one that's nice
dolly out a little bit oh you guys
aren't on the bridge in this picture
that's better it's all me anyway so
i'm i'm sorry i may have just caught a
fish from right next to wade's bait
are you kidding i'm gonna catch it too
we're gonna catch this thing caught
another white crappie i'm gonna take a
picture i'm gonna take a picture of me
taking a picture while you take a
picture
nice where it says like the number oh
got another one right under his nose
hell yeah how do i take a picture i
think you just
hold up your phone to your screen
there's something there's something
wrong with my pretty sure [ __ ] this keep
that one
and keep that one
[Music]
whoa a dragonfly landed on my fishing
pole
really cool
is it magical it was pretty magical for
me
i mean it sounds pretty amazing yeah hey
go check out that worm pile buddy plenty
of food there for you
all right have a good one that was nice
i'm sorry talking to the dragonfly
yeah yeah that's cool oh did you have
any questions for dad
i forgot oh yeah dad why is my pee pee
hurt
all the time
dad it's real really bad
we ever ever um do you ever um
do you ever watch down there buddy no i
stay away from it just like jesus
wants
jesus yeah say jesus some more
i don't know about that man yeah calm
down
[Laughter]
i'm going cheese cheese is this i think
we should go to a new place i think
that's what we need okay
unlock the new place later nerd wait
where are you going bob where are the
cool people going i don't think i can
leave
any villa efficiencies all right sure
let me know when it is i think mine's
locked
okay where i'm going mark where'd you go
what was the place called
the one in the czech republic it's the
only other one we have unlocked right
now
well you go from texas right to the
czech republic well they're really
biting
they're really biting on this friends
room wade you got to get in here hurry
got another one baby
oh he's tiny he literally could not be a
smaller crappie
yeah it could it could be the [ __ ]
ones that are biting my rod
hey i'm level four i unlocked a bunch of
new stuff
nice man congratulations and mudwater
river in missouri
dude you're leading the way for us
you're really showing us how it's done
i'm a pioneer of fishing yeah yeah you
are
wait i think what you do what you got to
do if you want to catch more fish more
efficiently yeah
you gotta talk to them fishy fishy fishy
i will literally pay for your [ __ ]
children's
college tuition if you don't like god
what's threatening maybe
comment down a little i will
buy you a brand new car wait it says
wait they want a car
they want a car yeah hey
look at me yes am i level
no but you're but you're
learning you're progressing yeah having
a lot of luck in the czech republic
there
oh man i'm having no luck
well well well no i'll the bluegill have
turned
maybe they don't understand your your
brides
what are you trying to bribe them with
like vodka well brad mostly
who's the white crappy in the czech
republic now hey i was on your side man
i was on your side the whole time
i expected that uh bob but not you wade
i'm going to catch one right now
uh get creative with it i got some worms
on there
i caught a common roach point six pounds
0.6 is literally the combination of the
last two or three fish i've caught
are you high enough level to go to czech
republic that way i don't
where do you see your level uh it would
have been a lot of flashing lights we
would have
yeah something would have popped up and
then like you unlocked new bombers
i imagine i need to catch like one more
you can do it buddy
so i had to do i had to do a phone call
this morning where i had to like do some
i was canceling internet at the old
house and so this conversation i knew
was going to be a pain in the ass
started with this woman being like hey
they
were calling in internet company my name
is karen uh how can i help you today i
i would be like yeah i just need i just
need to cancel my account i we move you
guys you know we don't have
your company doesn't have service set
our new address and she was like oh i
can check on that for you
and every time my brain was like no
karen
i had to restrain myself so hard
she was totally nice and it was
undeserving
but everything she said because like you
know they do the sales thing where
they're like oh well you do you need
cell phone service or do you want uh
like satellite tv in your house and
every time my brain was like no
karen but then my mouth was like oh
thank you when i was trying to we were
having internet issues i was calling i
was like please can you guys like give
it
does anyone have higher internet speeds
can you guys like up your internet speed
they're like it looks like you got the
maximum internet speed i was like okay
well
but i was like oh we can't offer you
more channels on your table
if you would like to add a phone i was
like no i don't i just literally i only
called by the internet i
of hbo understand max yeah
i know that these people are just
selling everything so they're not
necessarily experts
but i [ __ ] hate talking to those poor
sales reps on the phone about internet
like when we moved to this house i
looked online and they were like 10
megabits
down and three up and i was like oh
cool okay and and i like the company we
were with before so i called them and i
was like look i looked at my address
on the online system and it said that
this was the service i was just going to
see if that's accurate or if there's
like like
you guys that can upgrade the service or
whatever every time the guy's like well
that's pretty good internet how many
devices are you going to have on your
network
like no no no do you think it's like i
don't know like someone passes away like
you know grandma or something passes
away and you're like okay i gotta call
and cancel the
first tv and internet subscription
obviously we're gonna be selling the
house you call and they're like
yeah sorry my loved one passed away i'm
gonna have to cancel my the internet
but sir have you heard of our new offer
for you the bundle
remember your grandmother with his 200
new
channels if i was that sales person i'd
be like you want to cancel the last
shred of your grandmother that you have
in your life
you keep this plan listen i can maybe
get you 10
off a month i'm looking at her tv
history she'd be watching channel 34
right now you're going to get rid of
that
you know i actually knew janice pretty
well and she was
just about to add our special hbo
showtime combo package that she was just
telling me
the other week she loves watching old
movies
and she said yes even if i die
tell my surviving family i want the
showtime package every time i've gone
moved someplace i always ask the same
question which is like hey what's the
internet here and they always respond
internet you say why i don't know like
as if they've never
had internet asked about anything in
their life
oh i'll do some research i'll go to the
library and find out
and it's like she's crazy they're trying
to get anyone
to distinguish between download speed
and upload speed
god yes that is such a pain in the end
i can't even remember how many times i
had the conversation of like yes yes
okay it's 750 down
what is the upload speed and there's
like oh
oh 750 internet
it's internet 750 so that means you get
750 internets
yeah i literally just dealt with that
with two different companies we've been
on spectrum here and yeah it was like
they just kept harping on there like sir
you're never going to need more than 300
megabytes downloads
yeah i [ __ ] know what but 20 upload
is not it's not working right now do you
have any better upload speed
than like 300 down you shouldn't need
more internet
i had someone who tried to convince me
nothing is bit i've not even gotten
nibbles
meat um i'm trying to change it back to
the bread that worked last time
i've had no luck in the czech republic
i've gotten that one fish and that was
it hey wait i caught one
oh congrats man man how many fish over
there are you doing it
i did it oh it's a european perch
i will buy you dinner and make sweet
love to you in the pale moonlight if you
just bite my
hook oh okay and with that my career is
over
lexi and make this great make this video
fantastic
[Music]
you